you might recall we're looking at growth
in decay but we move into extension one
layer when we said modified growth okay
the example I gave you when something is
dropping in temperature but the ambient
temperature isn't zero so therefore as
it decreases in decreasing because it is
not an approach zero it's going to
approach whatever your ambient
temperature is and we call that e for
environment when we look to temperature
and we looked at when you go an
environment that has some kind of non
zero temperature we can't reduce we
actually developed Newton's law of
cooling do you remember what it was i'll
give you clues it starts like this okay
first thing it's cooling right so minus
okay right what's yep okay so we look at
this and we were saying rather than
regular a regular intake a situation
where it's minus KT it's dropping in
proportion to what your temperature is
we're dropping your proportion to the
difference between your temperature and
the environment temperature that's team
on T now this talked about when your
decaying you're going down to a level
it's not zero but one of that situations
like this when you're not decaying what
you're going up towards something but in
a similar way there's some kind of limit
hospet you cannot grow any further okay
now populations tend to do this you know
they grow sort of exponentially to a
certain point but then what kind of like
the moderate on question what kinds of
things get in the way of a population
just growing little sleep okay number
one resources okay resources a very
broad word what kinds of resources are
we talking about number one food what
else shelters space keep you need
physical space to live okay not only do
you start right up against those
limitations but as you hit like safe
space problems you get overcrowding
which means that sort of transmission of
disease happens faster right so all of
the plagues of like the 1000 to 2000 s
they all started in cities because of
this problem okay and of course things
like the common flu so therefore I want
to think about what happens when a
population so what I've reaches this up
love it keeps
growing okay but it has a cap on it now
this is not a technical name it's just
kind of a descriptive name I want to sit
think just like we did before with
Newton's law of cooling what does this
look like visually and therefore what
kind of equation we're going to get so
he comes graph number one regular growth
regular it looks like this like we are
familiar with this you're going to have
your your time intercepts there so I
know you're trying to intercept your
population or temperature or whatever
intercept you turn a great situation
into a decay situation by doing what how
much angels leave a to the minus KT
right if I go like this because your
time axis is the horizontal one like so
slapping a minus sign on on the front of
that lower case T flips things
horizontally because that's your
horizontal axis so this is the situation
okay now if I want to think about like I
want this kind of shape right I want it
slowing down but I want it slowing down
as I increase not as I decrease okay so
if I want something that's going up but
in the same way like this right you can
see how I moved from two to three how am
I going to change the equation of the
situation yeah so just like here i SAT
the minus sign on the front of the T to
flip horizontally hero sappy a minus
sign on the front of the well on the
whole thing and that fit be vertically
okay there's one last thing we need to
adjust because here you'd expect we're
thinking about positive populations so
just like we did with the first modify
growth in the case situation i'm going
to introduce a vertical shift i want to
go up thanks for something like this we
really should have some asymptotes of
all of these
okay so if we have a look at this we can
think about on Boober ton of these guys
opinion in this is used to me oh I don't
think I need to write it's already there
thank you sir see it's like you can't
count on anyone can you and it's just
last time when we had the decay
temperature right i just added a number
right if we call this like your maximum
population or something like that let's
suppose that this is a population equals
I don't know let's call it m for maximum
ok so that's why our intercept there how
does that change this equation right
this is this verdict reshape it up by M
units right so the equation of this will
be and take away AE to the minus KT do
you agree do you see how i started with
growth I went to decay i modified this
DK situation to turn it upside down so
it had this growing idea and then I just
gave it some numbers so that it actually
made sense so we won't actually have
this now if I think about this equation
okay okay if P equals M minus okay where
m is the maximum what kind of
differential equation what kind of de
will this obey well as usual all we have
to do is just drink it and find out
right so I'm looking for a dpdt
here right what happens to them
disappears to constant after all what's
going to happen in here I want to write
okay I've got two negatives that are
cancelling out so that's why that's done
i'm going to write hey that's already
there e to the minus KT did I account
for everything I'd on the inside Don the
outside now I want to get this back in
terms of the original function P right
so we'd have to do that adding
subtracting thing I did before if I take
out a factor aw ok what am I going to
put in here this is just just taking a
factor out interestingly remember how on
this line it's like oh I've got a
negative and it's cancelled out but I
actually kind of still want that don't I
cuz look look at this guy I actually
want that negative in there do you see
that so if I it slap a negative back
means I bring it back in here okay now
what
screw that have a look at that that's
the population right okay just compare
that you've got Newton's law of cooling
down in your book right how different is
that two needles are cool not very
different at all which shouldn't
surprise us because we arrived in ian's
Laura Cooley by doing much the same
thing and doing this shifting around all
that's really different is like what are
these things here temperature rather
than a population a maximum population
Syrian he can't go past as opposed to
the environmental temperature but both
of them are doing the same thing they're
both heading towards here and of course
if the population was equaled soothe and
then you're going to have no change
broke you hit the ceiling daddy does
that make sense